c'est enfin le retour des beaux jours et
avait que l'opération mais à vélo une
initiative nationale qui vise à
promouvoir le vélo sous toutes ses
formes pour l'occasion saint quentin en
yvelines a proposé une matinée de
découverte à la vélostation plusieurs
associations locales étaient présentes
objectif présenter les services en place
on aide les personnes à réparer leur eux
mêmes leur vélo donc on leur apprend les
petites réparations tout ce qui est
crevaison changement de patins de frein
réglages de dérailleur on fait aussi de
la vente de vélos d'occasion la
vélostation c'est un service qui est
proposée par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui propose trois
services différents donc il ya de la
location de vélos la location de places
de consignes et à un atelier de
réparation aujourd'hui dont nous sommes
à 50 m pour une pour présenter
l'information mécanicien vélo écossais
technique vélo c'est surtout la
réparation la maintenance et la
réparation de vélos parmi les
associations le groupe vélo sky antenne
de l'association mieux se déplacer à
bicyclette qui réunit une centaine
d'adhérents plusieurs actions et
activités sont proposées dont une pour
apprendre à faire du vélo c'est
l'opportunité pour des personnes qui
n'ont jamais appris à faire du vélo de
devenir en confiance dans un tout petit
groupe généralement on a trois quatre
élèves maximum en même temps ils m'ont
rassuré - april et bab à chaque fois
beaucoup d'encouragements
aujourd'hui c'est pas parfait mais deux
mois après jc en faire je peux faire un
pack ou une journée qui vise aussi à
démontrer que le vélo est un sport qui
se démocratise de plus en plus je suis
de l'eau quotidiennement pour aller
faire des courses au centre commercial
pour venir à la médiathèque ou pour
aller ailleurs c'est le moyen le plus
rapide le plus économe c'est le moyen le
plus écologique on a quand même beaucoup
de pistes cyclables bien entretenu il
faut croire aux associations locales
faux
se dire qu'avec la présence du vélodrome
justement on va pousser dans le sens là
et que ça deviendra vraiment une ville
amie des vélos et si vous avez vous
aussi l' envie de vous mettre au vélo le
groupe vélo sky vous donne rendez vous
le dimanche 5 juin pour relier saint
quentin en yvelines à paris avec des
milliers d'autres cyclistes